and here's another thing that I've said
to you before and I know that you're
gonna hate me bringing it up and I don't
know why you're ashamed of it is that
thing we talked about in the elevator
what reality television yeah yeah I'm
not ashamed of me now so I started out
in reality TV I was a road rules cast
right in 1999 and they don't have the
show anymore oh I'm sorry
no you remember it I agree I grew up
watching you but I grew up in bro put a
flag patch on no I grew up in Georgia
and I used to write all the time oh
that's awesome man yeah it's good yeah I
mean it was just a wild time I guess
it's just because it's hard to like it's
not hard to separate from it it's just
like it was just I was so young you know
I'm 37 now like I was 19 oh my god
doesn't count it just doesn't it does it
and also I'm going to say this okay is
is that if because I don't I don't never
seen the show I've heard of it
I don't know that you're from there yeah
and a lot I think a lot of comics are
like that a lot of comes in or old or
like you know what the [ __ ] is that we
don't we've heard of it but you know you
your merit it's what you are now that I
judge you by yeah okay and what I see is
a comic a real comedian with real chops
who's in a ghost places yeah and for you
to get spots at the store The Improv
Laugh Factory on nightly basis which is
what you do yeah to do headline I know
what rooms you play yeah they're all all
a list rooms yeah
that's not you know a reality show guy
that's a real comics right you know life
yeah so it's like it's something that
you did in the past but I think it's
interesting to do a show like that show
what's called rules and to reinvent
yourself
that's right Jamie Chung I know you went
to this rally Chengdu she was on the
real world
Christina provin ski what did she do
pazsitzky was a road wheels cast right
is hilarious yeah yes only you know in
certain instances you can come from a
show like that yeah what I swear to
[ __ ] god when I left MADtv
I couldn't get auditions because the
casting directors would be like yeah
he's from MADtv yeah it was a negative
thing mm-hmm right so I just went all
right I'm just gonna go back to stand
out they don't want me mmm and then you
see key and Peele Jordan you know Keegan
I got bunch of people do well I'm doing
okay yeah
and now those things are not said
anymore it's more of a thing oh they're
from that right right but for many years
I was ashamed of it I really was it was
like a shameful thing really yeah
because nobody wanted like it there was
a sense of like that it wasn't cool
right right and and it wasn't I don't
think at the time but if you look at
who's come from there the lineage the
comedy lineage I mean the people even
writing like oh yeah yeah I mean Colton
Dunn who's on superstore superstore but
he was a one of our writers yeah years
Michael Hitchcock from all the
Christopher Guest movies was one of our
producers I mean there's a Lana when we
would go to MADtv we would hang out with
Eugene Levy and all these guys that used
to hang out there John Candy's daughter
I mean all the SA TV the history of it
would be there but we in terms of the
media or in general the country we no
one give a [ __ ] right but I can't change
my past and when they offer me the show
I took it yeah because what am I also
gonna do yes opportunity yeah and I did
it and I'm fine my career is fine why my
point though is is that you came from
there but it's nothing to be ashamed of
yeah and I remember like you know I used
to bring you up like that you didn't
like it I won't I understand why then
yeah because you want the audience you
know I mean but I just think that you
should never run from it dude because
people don't respect you I get what
you're saying because
stigma attached to reality TV in general
and the types of characters that are in
reality TV today which you know you know
it you do it's a stigma yeah so it is
when you don't have talent yeah you're
right yeah you know you you know one
piece you know a lot of these guys it's
a lottery they won a lottery ticket but
then some people actually have Talent
yeah real talent and at 19 if they were
to ask me to do rod roles I it would
have changed my life yeah I got no [ __ ]
I had no friends at 19 I was invisible
were you really ready oh absolutely I
walk into anywhere and no one saw me
yeah all right and so of course I would
have taken that at 19 yeah I mean I had
no plans of going to comedy or being a
comedian I didn't have any I was just
walking across campus at college and I
was just like really really depressed
and they had like auditions and then
next thing you know I was they called me
one day and they asked me to to go on
this trip you know and I was like oh
this is gonna be really really
interesting and then yeah and then
that's how I got into it I think the
part that kind of burned me was like or
the part that got to me was like
whenever I got out to LA years later and
I decided I'm gonna get in and I'm gonna
do stand-up some of it was there was
times where you know I liked making
people laugh because I always you know
like and this is part of alcoholism you
just I just never felt I always thought
people just didn't like me ever since I
was young it just some of those wrong
with me I had this ism where I thought
people just didn't like me and it just
there was nothing I could ever do in a
moment to feel any different and so I
knew if I was making people laugh that
they had to be liking me for that few
seconds because they couldn't hate you
can't not like somebody in laugh right
so it was like a real proof that I had
you know visually and so you know then I
got into making people laugh and and
then you would get out to like places
and then there was always just like
these dudes who had like come from other
cities or whatever who'd probably
auditioned to be on these reality shows
because like it was always those types
of people I would see when I go into
who would always kind of I guess made me
feel negative about it right you know so
I don't know if sometimes the the
feelings came from me as much as they
did probably just from some weird lack
of acceptance and back in Louisiana
people would like trying to fight me at
bars and guys would like I remember
people throwing bottles at me and like
it just got crazy and that's one of the
reasons why I left Louisiana was because
it got so crazy yeah you know it just
got out of jealousy right probably I
guess I get drunk [ __ ] this guy you know
you thought TV inward they call me the
n-word say what I'm like like I mean I'm
polish Nicaragua yeah yeah
so yeah just idiots you know I mean
there's a lot of idiocy in a lot of
places so but that made me feel that the
suffering yeah you coming to LA and you
know what to be honest it probably
wasn't good for you in the beginning
when you came to LA yeah right those
things could have been real that you
know they were like saying [ __ ] or
whatever right but the thing is is that
the suffering is key it motivates you
right to go I'm gonna get through this
yeah without suffering there is no
reward own true reward that's I believe
that yeah moments of me going oh my god
I'm out I will so done I will show you
yeah one day I will show you who and
that idea that feeling
I still have it'll never go away yeah
that I am gonna show you what I'm
capable of
yeah I think some of that hit me man I
got into me I was like okay like you
know I didn't even have a chance I was
making really any choices in my life I
was 19 and then now you guys are gonna
say oh this guy isn't you know talented
or this guy couldn't be an entertainer
you know or and I was like okay I'm
gonna take the hardest job to do I'm
gonna take stand up and I'm gonna do
that then yeah because then there's no
way that anybody could say they can say
whatever they want but with stand up
there's no nobody can help you I mean
they can get you up on that stage but
you got to have to be up there oh my god
you not only have to do that right you
are now following because the
the spots that you get are later right
yeah I mean you I've seen the lineups
where it's like heavy [ __ ] hitters
dude oh yeah and you go up there in
crush - oh yeah oh right one saying is
that that right there should show people
a lot yeah which is like that's a
legitimate soldier [ __ ] but I think
you're also at a point in your career
where I don't think anyone doubts that
anymore like right oh yeah you have a
you know you've been around long enough
as a stand-up that I don't think anyone
would ever question that about you at
least for me like I didn't know you from
real rules and yeah I saw you like there
was no doubt in my mind that your
legitimacy is 150% like I never thought
hmmm I wonder where this guy came from
yeah where he started it was like no
this guy's been doing stand-up all his
life that's what I thought right yo do
you have beer I'm gonna be real with you
right now do I promise you this man I
promise you this right now man okay
I never bring it up again but I just
needed to beat you up this one babe you
shouldn't have brought it up I know I'm
gonna I brought up this one time just to
address it yeah but you and I we're past
it all right will you speak up you and I
are past it okay and we're gonna move
beyond it okay no yes Ambro she thinks
that this when I do this right he's a
negative it is negative it is it is it's
negative it's positive it's not a gun
you know it because you know what you
don't see I can see it right now I blame
God's touching me right now - he is
where you don't see it but right okay
yeah okay
[Music]